[Aplausos]
un galardón que sabe a revancha la
futbolista catalana Alexia putellas alzó
su segundo balón de oro y vuelve a
brillar muy feliz de volver a estar aquí
muy contenta
la verdad que cuando hace un año
conseguimos ganar
el primero me propuse yo misma intentar
mejorar
pero vestida de gala y fuera de las
canchas reconoció que echa mucho de
menos sentirse futbolista no ha sido un
año fácil para putellas el 5 de Julio la
futbolista tuvo que dejar su ilusión de
disputar la Eurocopa una ruptura de
ligamentos de la rodilla la alejó del
balón que ha perseguido casi desde el
momento en que aprendió a andar
ahora empieza una nueva etapa desde que
tengo uso de razón jamás he estado más
de 5 días sin tocar un balón entrenar o
competir era y es mi pasión y será todo
un reto este proceso pero Confío en
recuperarme retomar el camino y terminar
lo que empecé
el camino comenzó en mollet del vallés
un municipio en la provincia de
Barcelona
en donde la catalana dio sus primeros
toques al balón con una calidad que la
condujo rápidamente al sabadell al
español y luego al levante y también
abrirse paso a la selección nacional
mientras crecía como futbolista putellas
también tuvo que enfrentarse a una
pérdida personal
en 2012 su padre falleció y ese mismo
año llegó al club de sus amores El
Fútbol Club Barcelona
ese por el que festejaban juntos cada
anotación vestida de azulgrana a la
futbolista llegó al momento cumbre de su
carrera
conquistó la liga española en cinco
ocasiones y en 2021 la catalana alzó la
orejona dándole la primera Champions
League al Barcelona femenino
botellas también brillan lo individual
En la temporada 2021 y 2022 fue la
máxima goleadora de la Champions League
la tercera anotadora en la liga y la
mejor asistidora de España
ahora putellas deberá ganar uno de los
partidos más importantes de su carrera
recuperarse de su lesión y Volver al
campo de juego